Okay, so the next question is, what
kind of backend stack do we want to use?
Now, I really want to get something
that's going to be quick to set up,
because we should get Shopping
List Plus Plus in users' hands as
fast as possible.
I'm pretty solid with Android, but
it's been a really long time
since I set up a server.
>> Well,
maybe you don't need to set up a server.
Have you ever heard of [SOUND] Firebase?
>> Hm, well, I'm intrigued,
I have heard of Firebase,
it's like a fancy database, right?
>> It's fancy, all right.
>> Okay.
>> Seriously,
Firebase is a collection of services,
including a database that can serve
as a simple backend for your app.
>> Okay, that sounds great, but
is it easy to use with Android?
>> Very easy.
It has an SDK for
Android as well as iOS and JavaScript.
With Firebase you write a little client
side code, and then Firebase takes care
of all the rest,
some authentication and access to data.
>> Well, I definitely like the idea of
not setting up a bunch of server code,
so I guess I could read up
on Firebase a little bit and
kind of prep the GitHub repository for
the developer.
>> In the meantime, I'll poke around and
set up an account, so you and
your developer can poke
around with the SDK.
>> All right, that sound great!
>> Follow me, and
let's get started with Firebase.